And here, only one statement is correct.
This statement down here is not correct.
The clique can not contain multiple vertices
from one of these groups,
and the reason why that is is
that in a clique, all vertices, as you know
must be connected to all other vertices,
but this is not how we constructed the graph.
When we constructed the graph, all we did was draw edges
between vertices from different groups,
but we did not allow any edges between vertices
in that group,
so if you find a clique
that can only contain exactly one vertex from each of these groups here.
So if the graph has a clique of size m,
and the clique can not contain
multiple vertices from a clause group,
this means that you have to have exactly 1 vertex
from each clause group in your clique.
So this statement here is definitely true.
It contains at least one vertex from each clause group.
But actually, we can make an even stronger statement and say
it contains exactly one vertex from each clause group.
And now we're almost done with our reduction,
because if you think about it, so
we solved clique for this graph we have constructed here,
and we asked the decision problem,
does the graph have a clique of size m
where m is the number of clauses?